hey where have you been oh you were
supposed to be here working i lost track
of time this is the real world sometimes
you just got to let your dreams go
i just scribble in my notebook i'm a
stock boy that's it you are a legit
designer
let me add them
[Music]
dude i love it
oh
i want to lick them
i'm kira oh hold up
kyra king aka sneaker royalty
boom the king's charity gala yeah design
some sick kicks show off your talent at
the most exclusive sneaker event of the
year that could happen this is your shot
come on get up
you've got sneakers to make
[Music]
it's you did you design these yeah
you're the guy
that everybody's been talking about
tonight this is destiny
is
my kids
[Music]
well i know a flop when i see one i was
like who's that is that young kevin
gates look like kevin gates this is one
of these movies that you see everything
in the movie in the trailer i'm not
gonna see i'm not gonna i'm not gonna go
see it you know what the hell happened
they made they take something cool and
make it corny
sneakerella someone someone took that
and said you know what's that's a good
idea we're gonna do yet another remake
he left his shoe on the escalator
who does that oh it's my curfew i gotta
go ruff they tried to make the
cinderella overlap so large that they
just didn't care how stupid it was yeah
they didn't care no
they they were all
she she's a royalty of a sneaker family
yeah for three generations your family's
been exploiting chinese people
now i will concede to this point this is
just me
this is a movie for kids yeah
okay it's not for us no it's not you're
too old for this [ __ ] it's not for us i
never looked at disney movies and
thought oh i needed representation
because one great thing about disney is
that i was looking at animals i was
looking at inanimate objects monsters
different looking people i remember even
watching like quasimodo
and hunchback of notre dame and i was
like okay you know so when i see this
new age stuff i'm like y'all are forcing
the point so bad yeah but it was it was
for you i think
it was for you because of where you were
brought up because you didn't know you
was black until you came back here
we knew we was black everything was
quite white a little bit of diversity
would have helped so i'm gonna give that
to them i'm gonna be like yeah you know
what yes because being here and knowing
that you're black at five at four or
five you're a kid and after that you go
back home and then everything you see is
white white white white white white
white white white white white white like
the norm is white so i would have wanted
a little bit of diversity when i was a
kid i'm going to say this cartoons had a
lot of diversity when cartoons hadn't
when i don't know when i was when i saw
that
the diversity in my cartoons it was a
lot of there was a lot of uh stereotypes
and minstrels but
yeah sure whatever will you be talking
like
that's what i grew up on okay
i still hate all of that [ __ ] was super
hella racist
you know what i mean so and then not
even that the looney tunes were [ __ ]
racist
i was [ __ ] up races and that's what i
was growing up on so a little bit of
positive diversity would have been nice
i would have appreciate that so if it's
the kids from if it's a movie for kids
and they have
black people in there i appreciate that
and if it's new people that i've never
seen i preach at least i'm gonna give
them that i'm appreciate that and that's
why i said i hope i hope that those kids
that are in that movie grow up to be
bigger actors that we're gonna see
elsewhere if other kids can see that and
be like oh [ __ ] a movie like that but
all the cinderellas that we had i had to
wait for the version of cinderella with
brandy and whoopi goldberg on that [ __ ]
it's like the mom was white that the mom
was black that was white that was brandy
and
brandy was cinderella and the kid was
somehow asian nothing was good about
where i was from nothing you're the only
[ __ ] country in in africa that was
not colonized y'all [ __ ] had
tangs
whole ass and prison [ __ ] like we didn't
have none of that when we were what we
represented was just that
bad [ __ ] we couldn't even speak creole
we couldn't speak french so that they
thought we would be cruel like none of
this [ __ ] so at some point yeah it's
important to see us somewhere that we're
okay and i can't understand that you
don't understand that because you i
don't disagree with what you're saying i
think diver i'm not mad at
representation if they want to put that
in but tell good stories tell real
stories when i watch the boondocks you
know what i don't think representation
no i don't think no i just think it's a
real action this is just a great
well-written show i can relate
when i watch the jamie foxx show i
actually enjoyed it yeah i enjoyed it
i'm like that's just a good show yes
it's a black cast cooler represented but
the basis of it is is this funny fresh
prince as well the reason why french
gravitate towards everybody is because
it's just a great story at its base of
course the diversity aspect afterwards
comes on top of it in layers on top but
if you lead with that if you make that
your selling point i'm always going to
assume your [ __ ] is going to be corny
because you're more concerned with how
it looks in the window still than how it
actually functions once you take it off
the shelf yeah and that's always been my
problem when i see stuff like this i
want these kids
to grow up with wonderful stories yeah
right and i don't want it to just be
centered around the black experience
right it doesn't always have to be
through that because you know this too
we have so many black movies right now i
watch queen and slim the one of the
worst movies i've ever seen in my life i
know yesterday i got so mad when i
watched that i turned it off after 30
minutes because it was just a lot of
like well you're black so let's talk
about school shooters and how they're
mostly white and let's talk about how
police treat you terribly let's talk
about black guys doing black power
symbols out of nowhere and it's just it
was just it was just symbolism
everywhere and it stopped being a movie
and entertainment and a story being told
they just started being like can we
virtue signal
right and it feels like that with this
as well we know black people love
sneakers so let's go through the sneaker
you know what have been actually
interesting what if it was a black kid
playing chess and you didn't force a
diversity angle but it was just a great
story i'll recently watch something
called the queen's gambit
netflix show it's about a ginger girl
who plays chess honestly even though her
sex is mentioned throughout you can tell
that that's not the angle that they're
going at when they're making the show at
least not from where i watched it was
just a really well done show with a
female lead and they didn't [ __ ]
shove it in your face all the time that
she's wonder woman you know what i'm
saying and i can appreciate that i just
thought it was a wonderful show i would
love it if we could get shows like that
and it's just not shoved in her face the
whole time that this is a black
individual take idris alba i watch the
show luther where he's the head
detective and it's a great four season
spanning show black lead a diverse set
of casts and you know what i never
thought watching that oh my god
diversity i'm sorry this is a great show
and i think that's what these kids need
more than anything they need to see
themselves represented not overtly but
maybe a little bit severely and it's
just a good entertaining show and i
think in that case you're going to feel
much more normalized than everyone's
like do you want to see this show which
includes you you know what i'm saying
because then it feels awkward hey it
includes her have this that's not what i
want i want a great story yeah and after
that if you make it realistic because my
life is
diverse
then i watch it yeah absolutely you ever
tried to been higher for diversity
quotas do you want to be like sold a
show because it's diverse the the check
box i've been
you know i've been there you know how i
feel about that i'm not a fan so i think
that's my show but i'm not mad at like
the difference in experience it's just
when i see shows like this i always
cringe a little bit on the inside and i
think there's better ways of going about
it and i also will say that if these
people care so much about diversity take
a chance start a uip but to me it's all
about bottom line
they're taking old movies rehashing it
re-patching it to it with like hey
here's some fried chicken because we
know [ __ ] love that [ __ ] hey here's
some water malone and sneakers because
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] you said water
alone
that's kind of that's how they say that
right so
it's like bruh just write a good story i
don't care if it's a black lead in it
just write a good story that's like a
real representation of story and just
cast the people i'm out of it no
you're 10 years older than me so it's a
different era but i'm telling you for
folks my age we grew up with different
cartoons absolutely i'm when i'm
watching hey arnold i don't go look oh
where is the black representation if you
have a great black cat absolutely or if
you're watching recess you have a
different set of characters right true
and so you watching a lot of these shows
and you're like cool also let's also be
honest a lot of the shows didn't even
involve human beings
and so when you're just looking at
animals and you're listening at their
voices you're like that's also the proud
family
you think what i'm saying yeah so he
grew up with that yeah so my generation
was like you know i'm 30 30 one
month
you know what's [ __ ] up i feel good
about not remembering my age because i
don't remember anybody else's age yeah
so i feel great like oh you don't
remember my baby
[Laughter]
what would you dream about
i
[Laughter]
but but that's the real [ __ ] and so i
get where you're coming
because i don't know my big brother he
would tell me like you would watch power
rangers
and that was a [ __ ] for him listen none
of this [ __ ] but i was like
really but let's be honest
the white power did you have to be white
but let's be honest
everything was corny back then
everything was corny it's not like just
[ __ ] was corny everything i watched
that power ranger as a tiny child like
i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
everything was corning me okay so it's
not like they just made the [ __ ] corny
the [ __ ] was
okay remember watching power rangers
there was the asian girl there was like
the three white people the asian girls
and the black guy the asian girl was
yelling yellow
the black rachel was black [ __ ]
but you know what the black ranger was
really cool yeah he was he was cool he
was that's not like dancing
and [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
also movies around your age
corny
some were there was also a lot of
classics oh yeah do you know what i'm
saying oh yeah if you talk about a media
standpoint i don't disagree with you
that those coin representation but at
least on the american side there was a
lot of good things on the american side
there was a lot of it was better it was
better just
just eddie murphy and the ensemble of
his work
comedians black comics at your time was
dominating it was it was great right so
there there is a bit of that balance my
thing is just i've got this rant queen
and slam [ __ ] was so [ __ ] bad
i've never turned off a movie 30 minutes
in before did you uh watch the
photographer i did it i liked it was
that keith it was good i liked it i
messaged the message
i messaged him too i'm like good movie
yes because the thing that
it was not so much about the struggle
but an interesting movie that has
trouble in it but it was not so much
about that
blah blah it was just is what it was
yeah i i appreciate it yeah and i like
the way he played i mean you know it's a
good little rom-com you know what i'm
saying
let me rephrase it's not a wrong comp
it's not it's
[Laughter]
a few jokes not even in bird box
is it bird box the first thing
all those easter egg movies where like
he's there to crack a few jokes and then
be like i'm here and you know get your
breath i'm not mad but every time i see
my mic say something funny
go ahead [ __ ] do your little dance hey
he's good at comic relief it's not so
much he's not though he's so bad he was
the worst part of ghetto
of get out yeah oh he wasn't get out too
i didn't see get out you don't want to
get up and watch i thought you got all
those movies he literally did all those
movies yeah he's somebody's uncle or
best friend or cop i don't know
you guys probably know what i'm talking
about um hey he's a dude that turned
into a big ass rant about movies bro but
i'm not hey it is
can we just not have movies about [ __ ]
and suffering out yeah i know i was
having a good time i would appreciate
that i would appreciate that you guys
want to watch a good old movie that's
funny and that involves like some black
folks and also charlie sheen's in it go
watch money talks i i showed it to the
guy recently and i rewatched it
was good i enjoyed it i laughed
oh i had this
chris tucker was killing it kill it
killing it but anyways let us know what
you guys think about our little rant did
we even talk about the movie
there's nothing to talk about so much
that's right what what do you want to
say about the movie that's fair first we
didn't see the movie it's just a trailer
and everything in the movie is in the
trailer
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments below if you guys want
us to expand we could talk about this
topic but uh
but yeah don't watch queen and slim
[ __ ] [ __ ] movie
[ __ ] move